[موسيقى]
البدايه من ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
فمع دخول الهدنه التي اعلنها رئيس الروسي
وبلاد ديمير بوتين حيز تنفيذ سنتابع الوضع
اذا مع مراسلنا من اكياس تامر صمادي ومن
كذلك من الجانب الروسي يتابعها مع مراسلنا
من موسكو امين ضرغامي وابدا معك امين واخر
المواقف الروسيه بعد تعرض دنيا بعض
[تصفيق]
نعم منذ دخول هذه الهدنه حيزه تنفيذ في
تمام منتصف هذا اليوم اعلنت السلطات على
ان القوات الاوكرانيه طبعا السلطه
المواليه لروسيا في دنيا اسقلانه القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت مدينه دمياط لوحدها اليوم
اربع مرات
واتهمت القوات الاوكرانيه بالقصف المدنيين
طبعا روسيا كانت منذ البدايه تؤكد على
انها ملتزمه بهذه الهدنه لكن رئيس دنيا
ولي لروسيا دونيس بوشيلينا اليوم قال بان
هذه الهدنه لا تعني باي شكل من الاشكال
عدم الرد على ما سماها استفزازات القوات
الاوكرانيه او اعطاء الجيش الاوكراني
مساحه من اجل اعاده همم في على الجبهات او
الدفع بالمزيد من التعزيزات او تحسين وضعه
العسكري على طول خطا التماس هذا طبعا
ينعكس بشكل مباشر
اه من خلال تصريحات وزير وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اليوم التي قالت انها القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ الدقائق الاولى لدخول همم
هذا همم طبعا هذه الهدنه حيزه تنفيذ بدات
بقذف همم الاحياء السكنيه وايضا مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني واكدت الوزاره على لسان
المتحدث باسمها ايجور كناشنكوف على ان همم
القوات الروسيه ردت على مواقع اطلاق النار
الاوكرانيه التي كانت قد استهدفت مواقع
روسيه في كل من
دونياسك وزباروجيا وايضا لوجان نستمع الى
ما قالته الوزاره في هذا الشهر
رغم التزام قواتنا بهدنه وقفه اطلاق النار
اعتبارا من الساعه الثانيه عشر بتوقيت
موسكو اليوم وصل النظام كيف المدفعيه على
المناطق السكنيه ومواقع القوات الروسيه في
محور كريسنو لمان ومنطقه بيروغروفكا
بجمهوريه لوغانسكي الشعبيه كما اطلقت
القوات الاوكرانيه ثمانيه قبائل في مدفعيه
على مواقعنا في بلده نوفو بابلوكا بمقاطعه
زبوجيا لكن قواتنا تصدق بمران المضاده
لمواقع القوات الاوكرانيه التي انطلقت
منها تلك الهجمات
التي لم تعترف بهذه الهدنه منذ الاعلان
عنها
نعم مريم هذه الهدنه في الحقيقه ولدت ميته
منذ اللحظه الاولى بالنسبه لكيف السلطات
الاوكرانيه رئيس الرئيس الرئيس الاوكراني
ايضا تحدث في هذا المضمون واشار بان
السلطات الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه
المرابطه على طول الجبهات في الجنوب
والشرق لن تعترف بهذه الهدنه هي قرئت من
قبل الحكومه الاوكرانيه انها تاتي في سياق
او في محاوله
لاعطاء فسحه من الاستراحه للقوات الروسيه
المتواجده على خطوط القتال لاسيه ما في
منطقه الدوم بس
وقالت السلطات ان هذه الهدنه على الرغم من
انها لا يعني لا تعبر بضعه ساعات الحديث
عن 36 ساعه فقط الا انها قد توقف عمل
القوات وتقدم القوات الاوكرانيه وكان
هنالك في الحقيقه خطاب الرئيس الاوكراني
وجهه باللغه الروسيه
للمواطنين الروس وقال بان النظام
الاوكراني الحكومه الاوكرانيه كانت تقدمت
بالفعل بمجموعه من النقاط المتعلقه باتفاق
سلام في حال وافقت عليه روسيا قال بان
القاده الروس لم يوافقوا على هذه النقاط
وتحدث بان انهاء الحرب
يكمن في حل بسيط وهو انسحاب كامل القوات
الاوكرانيه من الاراضي همم او الروسيه
عفوا القوات الروسيه من كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والحديث ايضا همم تكرر على
لسان العديد من المسؤولين السياسيين وهو
الانسحاب من شبه جزيره القرد همم مستشار
الرئيس الاوكراني اندرياس مكتبيه ايضا
تحدث ايضا خلال دقائق الاخيره واشار بان
حصيله الهدنه الروسيه المؤقته همم هي
اعلان حاله التاهب الجوي في كياب وعموما
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه وتحدث عن تحركات
وصفها بالمريبه للطيران الروسي في همم
سماء بلا روسيا وقال بان من الهدنه اليوم
هو بقاء العديد من الاطفال في الملاجئ
البارده
وقصف خيرسون وعندما نتحدث عن قصف خيرسون
السلطات الاوكرانيه هناك كانت تحدثت عن
اربع انفجارات خلال الساعات الماضيه وقصف
متواصل للقوات الروسيه من قبل القوات
الروسيه للمدينه والحديث عن احد مراكز
الدفاع المدني وتحدثت السلطات والقياده
العسكريه هناك عن مقتل عدد من المسعفين
وجرح اخرين هذا ما يخص خير سول لكن
بالتاكيد بالتاكدات الاوكرانيه ضلت
متواصله على عدم الاعتراف بالهدنه ميخائيل
البطولات تحدث مطولا في هذا السياق وهو
احد المستشارين في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
وقال بان المعدات والاسلحه العسكريه التي
باتصل الى اوكرانيا من شانها ان تجعل
القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم كثيرا على القوات
الروسيه الاساسيه مع انه تحدث عن معدات
واسلحه نوعيه واشار ايضا الى ان ال- همم
الاس العسكريه الجديده لمساعدات العسكريه
الجديده من شانها ان تحفظ وتحصن الاجواء
الاوكرانيه وهذا طلب كان يتكرر كثيرا على
لسان الرئيس الاوكراني طيله الايام
الماضيه عندما كان يطالب بدفاعات ارضيه
متطوره من شانها ان تحسن سماء العاصمه
كياب والمقاطعات الاخرى العاصمه التي تعرض
طيله الايام الماضيه لقصف صاروخي وايضا
بطائرات من دون طيار ووزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني كان له تصريحات مهمه ايضا خلال
الساعات الماضيه عندما تحدث عن ان الايام
المقبله وان هذا العام سوف يكون عام حاسم
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه همم وبناء عليه
وبناء على المساعدات التي تصل للجانب
الاوكراني من شان كل ذلك ان يعجل في النصر
الاوكراني كما اشار الحديث عن النصر
الاوكراني يتكرر منذ الليله الماضيه على
لسان الرئيس الاوكراني ومستشاري الرئيس
والحديث ايضا تكرر على
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني بالاضافه الى
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني كان هنالك حديث مهم
لوزير الدفاع الاوكراني خلال الساعات
الماضيه على احدى القنوات المحليه وتحدث
باسهاب عن المساعدات العسكريه التي باتصل
الى اوكرانيا هذا العام وقال بان هذه
المساعدات من شانها ان تعيد كامل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وان تطرد كما اشار ووصف القوات
الروسيه من المناطق التي تتواجد فيها
لاسيه ما في زبرجا او في بعض مناطق
زباروجا وخيرسون والحديث ايضا الدباس
وبالتاكيد شبه جزيره القرم تحدثت كثيرا
وزير الدفاع واشار الى انه بحكم الامر
الواقع باتت اوكرانيا اليوم عضوا في
الناتو من غير من دون ان يعلن عن ذلك بشكل
او كريم
الشمس
على احدث الاسلحه والتقنيات الغربيه لقد
دمرنا اسطوره ما يسمى الجيش الثاني في
العالم وتبينا انه عباره عن فقاعه العاديه
شكرا جزيلا لكما